[Music]
so
they have the freedom of expression
awards
there's a freedom of expression awards
which is really really exciting
uh there's a freedom forum and somebody
is going
somebody that you'll never believe is
going to get a freedom of expression
award okay
so let's let's just play it let's watch
it together
i'm so excited to be here tonight to
present susan wojcicki with the free
expression award
that's right um person who runs youtube
is getting the
free expression award well can i just
say something [ __ ] i think
uh this is an amazing move and i want to
say congratulations
uh to susan and the whole youtube team
frankly i mean everybody over there
you're just doing
doing really ever since you got
re-monetized great work well you know
sometimes royce you gotta recognize
uh people in in the field of tech for
the uh
for all the things they did to fortify
the election and susan i thank you
frankly as the ceo of youtube susan is
facing some of the most critical issues
around
free expression today when billions of
people are on your platform
every day how do you tell which ones are
white supremacist and not allowed to
talk on your platform susan comment
how do you make sure that everybody has
a voice but also feels safe
and how do you do that across the
versions of youtube that exist
in 100 different countries and 80
different languages
these questions are important to me
because youtube you're reading a script
that susan probably gave you
or her team gave you is where i found my
voice
you might not be able to tell by looking
at me but i'm blind
she's blind so you're saying i gotta i
kind of understand why
why she gave susan the award now it
makes total sense
she's blind i'm sorry i thought susan
wojcicki was the person for project
veritas i don't
no wonder she gave susan the award but
you are saying that there's a shot then
right
blind right i want to let you know ma'am
that i am
you know i am most women find me
irresistible
um it's just weird it's very odd that
you and i met on this day you're blind
and uh i'm the most
gorgeous man that ever lived what are
the odds
ah you want to get a drink later
you might not be able to know what the
best part about a blind chick she can't
see you putting
i say that that is a beautiful thing
jesus mike
[Laughter]
sorry was susan getting a little trophy
looking at me
but i'm blind i lost the majority of my
vision when i was 14 and that year it
felt like my life was falling apart
until i found a group of girls online
who loved beauty and fashion and that's
gotta suck huh
that's gotta be weird you know when you
lose your vision because then how do you
find it
right
how do you know when to stop wiping
smell i guess
do you smell the paper
[Laughter]
or do you just do you just over wipe
to be super cautious you know
when i no longer had friends in real
life to turn to i found
these online i'm sorry i gotta ask a
question
people stop being your friends because
you became blind
who the [ __ ] would do that yeah those
are some pretty terrible friends
you pick horrible friends you know my
mom used to say you know
if if you you know if you if they don't
if they're if they're
gonna like [ __ ] treat you like [ __ ]
for not doing what they want to do then
they're not really your friends
that wasn't going blind so i can't
imagine
to be fair all of our friends before
were deaf mutes so now what
happened the problem is that she spent
her whole life in the archery club
so all of her friends were were
world-class archers
and then they were like well i mean yeah
we'll still hang out with you but
like not as much because we're always at
the archery range
creators to turn to and they felt like
my friends
i knew that one day i wanted to be able
to build that same sense of community i
spent my first 14 years on this planet
trying to be the world's greatest
sharpshooter
and then i went blind it's very horrible
yeah but knowing knowing how accepting
everyone is now that price the letter in
the olympics
you want to be a drone operator for the
air force no that's matters anymore
other people around the world who felt
like they didn't fit in
six years ago that's what i did now
every single day
i get to share my story and advocate for
a world that's more accessible
for everyone youtube
this blonde chick too it'd be funny just
to [ __ ] with her
just to throw her off her game he'd be
like stop staring at the camera it's
weird yeah it's something
or start darting around looking weird
gave me that opportunity and every day
youtube gives people the opportunity
to express themselves and the freedom to
feel like they have somewhere
that they belong the freedom that
youtube gave me
is so important to me and i'm so
grateful and that's why i feel honored
to introduce to you
susan wojcicki the ceo what if it's a
guy pranking her but she can't tell
because it's blind
what if it's eric andre in a wig
[Laughter]
dude 10 years ago ericandre would have
done something like that
yeah what's up i'm susan wojcicki thank
you for this award
i appreciate it i will cherish it i will
honor it
as he's throwing it on the ground in
front of her because she can't see
oh of youtube she's been called one of
them so you're a youtuber too so how do
you
first of all those eyebrows are on fleek
for a blind girl yes
very good work secondly how do you like
when you're doing your
youtube show or whatever how do you do
like the color balance and
because like i can see and
i dread setting up the cameras as you do
every day for this [ __ ]
for doing obs stuff so how do you do
that
someone's got a good point why would
andre need a wig if she's blind fair
enough he wouldn't need a chain
commitment to the bit bro he does commit
himself andre commits to the bit let's
be fair
for us women in technology today but
oh i'm sorry i just we need to point
this out
because we completely missed it this
award is sponsored by youtube
well yes so susan let me put this up so
people could see it
so so susan is giving herself an award
is this a bad time to announce that rotc
media will be
issuing me with a lifetime achievement
award she's
she's she's giving herself the award
we should give ourselves an award dude
we should set up a whole award
show right like five different
categories and then we just keep take
turns
sweep the category taking turns winning
the award
but for creators around the world we
just know her as susan
let's take a look at her work i mean
i've heard
her called other things i'm not going to
repeat any of them here
because frankly they're disgusting but i
have heard other names
susan ogiski looks like a snail
i mean she looks like her best friend
should be a sponge
if if you were going to make an animated
like a pixar
film about a snail i can see it
you can see she's you're a pixar snail
susan
shaping the way that over a billion
people
access and her sister is shaping the way
we categor catalog and uh
permanently record all of your dna
profiles that's pretty cool
bravo
she is unquestionably one of the most
powerful media executives on the planet
and if i don't say that i will be
demonetized then they will keep my money
kick me off of youtube
video has never been easier to create
it's never been easier to watch
and so we think about ourselves as a
platform for the next generation of
media companies
that's what you were you were that
platform for the next generation of
media companies
which means again youtube which used to
mean hey man anyone can make a video
now she's at least she's being honest
right and going like this is for the
media companies that are coming up the
next generation of media companies royce
you know those hot cutting edge
companies like
msnbc cbs and cbs news wow
cnn wow next generation
to be able to create content and to
distribute it to the world
and i also really care deeply about the
freedom of expression
she cares very deeply about it royce
what
no you don't you don't you don't think
so no you don't
you never have
want to go down the list of people that
have been de-platformed and demonetized
we're demonetized and the fact that
people all over the world can use it to
tell their story
as long as they're black women as long
as the videos say are you a feminist or
a womanist
are you a feminist or a womanist a
question a lot of black women
black women are not asking that question
the rundown
101 can't even put like what i love
about this too
is they won't even include the milk
toast ones
like i would be a little bit less like
right for optics wouldn't you go
all right well they threw like dave
rubin in there or like crowder
but not even dave rubin or cry like do
you understand
you could sell your mugs and you could
be as clean as you want to be
and try to play by their rules but
they're still not going to let you in
they go where's tim poole
where's tim paul look we don't like
playing his guitar and doing six skate
tricks
i despise tim paul despise him jealous
he's completely full of [ __ ] and he is a
little bug man who's afraid to show his
bald head
i hate tim poole the passion but that
being said
he is representative of
a self-made successful youtuber right
like i mean whatever you want to say
about the guy
he carved a brand out and i know he's
milk toast he's a fence sitter i agree
but he played the game and he built a
little platform on youtube makes good
money and he's one of those guys
so like where like at least
throw a bone at this idea of having all
these stories being heard
and pop tim poole on your little brady
bunch grid over there
and please [ __ ] go all right hey they
got dave rubin and tim poole on there at
least
but not even them on the language of the
blind oh yes
[Music]
what she went out and bought a [ __ ] a
2 000
camera and a 500 microphone to tell us
that
i'm sorry but this could solve the
israeli
palestine issues right here did they has
anyone told them
hey guys the hate is the opposite of
love guys you've been set to hate all
this time you got to
set it to love like that doll from uh
the simpsons
god damn it you're right here it is
wasn't that the doll from the system
the nice and then and then they're like
why would you make this
important that we have a responsibility
framework
and that has been my number one priority
we're removing content that violates our
policies
you just said that free speech you just
you just
but you just said it youtube removes
thousands of videos pushing extreme
views
extreme views are still expression you
might not like them you may not agree
with them
and you know what that could be
completely wrong but when freedom of
express you can't win a freedom
expression award
and then in the look even if you're
doing this and she's doing this why
would you play this in the video like
like this is part of freedom of
expression
you can go too far what but that's not
freedom of expression
but it is rice you're free you're free
to express yourself
what within the construct of this little
box we've built for you
what and that can become censorship
that's like literally like having a pet
bird with like
the ends of its like wings cut off and
you have it in a little tiny cage
in your room and you go like wow that's
so sad for the bird
and you're like that bird is free that
bird is free to go anywhere in that very
comically small cage
anywhere he wants he can go up on that
little hangy thing
he could go down to where his water is
that big little bell and get him a bell
that bird is free as dare i say a bird
and you're like well no i think the ones
that
don't have their wings clipped and live
in a tiny cage are the ones that are
probably digging it more and so we have
been working really hard to figure out
what's the right way to balance
responsibility
with freedom of speech
[Music]
you can't you can't say freedom of
speech and then say it goes too far
one is an absolute and the and the other
one is not
all right i hear you i hear what you're
saying right
but they just did not only did they just
do that they're giving themselves an
award for it
yeah they're all going to get an award
and what are you going to do about it
well at least we know where the money
went a little plaque
also helping to reimagine and reshape
what's possible for women around them
why does why do all of the
here's my problem is that these
billionaires and all these rich people
that run these
companies right why do they all want to
reshape the world
like it's a creep like that is that
entire
impulse is rooted in narcissism it's
rooted in in being a psychopath
nobody should want to reshape the world
nobody should want to make everyone like
them
that's creepy and weird and it's it goes
against
what we're supposed to be doing as
humans and it's like
if i hear the word if i hear one more
billionaire a millionaire use the world
or i want to reshape
who i [ __ ] hate because if i had a
billion dollars tomorrow i'd be they'd
go what do you want to do more how do
you want to reshape the world
i'd be like yeah i just want everyone to
leave me alone
i have a billion dollars now and i
bought an island not
i'm just gonna play golf on it all day
and shoot guns in the air
and i'm gonna get drunk and die you'll
die in a month please leave me alone
ever since susan started running on
youtube the percentage of women in
youtube
has increased significantly is that's
terrible
representation the reason the percentage
of women has increased
because notice isn't a percentage is
because you've gotten rid of so many men
that obviously the female percentage
goes up if you get rid of men
matters if women do not participate in
tech
they're losing the chance to influence
the largest
economic and social shift of this
century influence the lar influence the
lord
listen to the words they're using and
they're winning and giving themselves an
award for
it this is like crazy
like this remember that old apple
commercial where they like threw a
[ __ ]
broke the screen because this is that
this is what's happening right now
influence why is it
they always project their own [ __ ]
at republicans and right-wingers right
and they're always just like these
people are fascists
these people are trying to commit
genocide they're trying to wipe out
you know they're trying to ruin the
world and all this but then like every
speech i see them
they're always talking about this
massive shift in a new era and a great
reset
and reshaping and it's like all they
talk about all they
think about at night is how to
create a globalist fascist society
and then they constantly go we gotta
watch those republicans folks
because they want to kill all your
non-white children that's like i don't
most of the republicans i know are just
like that texas woman we saw earlier
that's like
hey y'all coming to the barbecue because
again i made a lot of macaroni salad
y'all we ain't gonna let a lot of rain
stop us
we realize we have really broad reach
and we want to make sure that we
as a platform are using it for good i
know i can make it better
and that's why i'm here
susan i'm so honored to be able to
present you tonight
with a free expression award for your
incredible leadership with youtube and i
just want to say thank you
for all the work that you've done to
empower people around the world to share
their story
and i'm thrilled to be able to ask you
some questions about your perspective
on free expression now i sent you these
questions before and you approved them
and edited them
so just want to make sure these are good
all right but then i'm going to emanate
i'm going to ask you a bunch of
questions afterwards about your depth
perception
christ she went out with dan crenshaw
they'd have one good eye between the two
of them
could you imagine that i guess it's
ubers everywhere huh
thank you molly thank you so much for
being here and joining me here tonight
now i know that your passion i'm still
waiting to see like the barrel of a gun
poking in on one of the sides of the
screen with this other girl like so
anyway you've been really
like brave and and and and just so cool
i'm reading it i'm doing it stop just
just a tiny bit of the like the end of a
barrel put
every once in a while like a boom mic
like an errant boom mic on an old talk
show it just kind of pokes in the frame
free speech has been in part impacted
due to your family's
history can you share how your family's
experience specifically the early
history section is the part i'm
well let's find out i'm interested in
your ideas of free speech
sure well so on both sides of my family
they came to the united states because
of the need
or different kinds of persecution on my
father's side
it was due to political persecution my
father came from poland and
for a variety of reasons after world war
ii
um it became important for them to leave
and my father
escaped from poland and wound up coming
to the united states
and uh you know my grandfather was never
able to leave he remained in poland and
was behind the iron curtain
visa problems i saw how difficult it was
to communicate with him
to be able to worry about what you were
saying to him and for him to
have concerns about what was said or
what was even sent to him
and then on my mother's side they came
to united states for
religious persecution and so i've just
seen
the real benefits that freedom of speech
has as well as representing all people
of all different backgrounds so here's
the thing susan
i know she by the way she's doing her
best
look we goof on susan a lot right now
she tucker carlson through that
in a way like you you can tell she
doesn't want any memes
she doesn't want any clips she doesn't
want anybody but that was
wow so this is funny that she
tiptoed through that she mentions that
her her
grandfather wasn't able to come here
because and also uh
her other side of the family is a
religious persecution probably the
reason that he wasn't able to say what
he wanted to come over here is because
his views by a certain group of people
were considered extreme and they were
censoring his views because certain
people in power
found them extreme just food for thought
susan i don't see what has to do with
anything
i would say coral i you lost me
am i getting my award that's all i care
about we really can't take for granted
that we really have to
make sure that we're protecting them in
every way possible
and i feel um because of my family
history
a deep connection to to those freedoms
and i'm very thankful
for the freedoms that i have
like the freedom to censor you
absolutely as we all should be um now
when i
started on youtube i could see
goodnight everyone some of them are just
too goddamn good night everyone
sometimes it's just good night everyone
how many said it at home with us
it's the it's the go-to it's the go-to
joke right
she's hot though give her that much well
i mean yeah she runs youtube there's
something about power that's who's in
your [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] um
all i really wanted to do was just be
authentic and share
my story but of course as i've grown
there's been more pressure to speak
for others in my community and with that
becomes a lot of responsibility
and i know at youtube i have a question
how do you read super chats
i'm not being dick i'm being
honest well susan she's trying with
susan so they have a braille super chat
system
i was gonna say i mean i i pride myself
on being decent at reading
uh you know but i get if i get a couple
drinks in me i can barely read those
things i know nick rickett is the same
way how do you read them lady
guys are always juggling responsibility
at such a high level
always needing struggling something else
you can't do
to try to balance people's right to free
speech
with protecting our community from
content that can be harmful so can you
talk to us a little about that
yeah can you can you do me a favor and
uh explain to the audience how you can
reconcile
giving yourself a little cute trophy
that your company's giving
you that you've ordered your employees
to give you
um can you reconcile accepting that
trophy with the fact that you also
in the same expectant speech admit that
you censor speech that you don't like
and go and please give three minutes
and night waves to monetization well
first of all we wanna be able to have
as diverse and open a platform as
possible
and represent as many views as possible
on the platform
but we also need to make sure that there
are limits and that we can see that
sometimes
that um we've always since the very
beginning of youtube have had community
guidelines because we've realized that
there are certain types of content
and you're right and at the beginning of
youtube there were community guidelines
and honestly at the very beginning
the guidelines were like hey you know
don't make threats don't make death
threats don't
you know do anything that's overtly
illegal and for the most part you'd be
like okay again
that makes sense basically don't do
anything that's already probably covered
by some law
by some other law yeah exactly
um like some in the very beginning we
wouldn't allow um
adult content hate content um dangerous
content all of those types of content
could really make it
that youtube was no longer a platform
that was viable for all these other
voices out there
and so we've always had community
guidelines but as youtube has become
bigger
and has had more of an impact we've seen
the need to increase what we're doing
from a responsibility
standpoint and this has been an area of
increasing importance for
us as we have certainly gotten bigger
and we call this whole work
the responsibility work and we actually
talk about the
four r's of responsibility corporate
culture is
literally satanic the responsibility
what
it's literally satanic
these [ __ ] corporate cultures and
their little
[ __ ] cutesy their cutesy ways of
describing censorship
and destroying people's livelihoods is
like we called the response
we call it our responsibility doctrine
see what happened was we'd noticed for a
while that um
you know free speech uh comes with
problems
here and we've noticed that with hate
speech on the rise
the rise of fascism the rise of neo we
we decided that uh these problems that
we had
on the platform required uh a solution
if you will a solution that uh
carried with it some sort of like real
finality some closure you know some sort
of
ultimate solution type situation
it's like they don't even realize that
they sound like the bad guys now
so we sent all of our employees to what
we call a responsibility camp
where they would learn how to sort of
concentrate
more on uh our corporate culture
and our policies uh uh camps if you will
where they could be
re-educated reshaped remolded in our uh
in and then if they don't uh then we
crush them
you know the yuge it's like they just
don't see how any of that might start
it really becomes like one of those
[ __ ] old comedy like uh
throwaway gags where it's like are we
the bad guy wasn't that was it monty
python that did the are we the bad guys
are the baddies
are we the baddies here it's literally
thousands of people
and a large amount of work across the
entire company
but uh but uh if i summoned into these
four different r's
the first one would be remove which is
that we're always updating our policies
and
content yes because you know
somebody else then again we're trying to
compare but
uh somebody else had a had a 4r system
that started with remove remember that
was yes remember remove was step one
and you see there was this dude in the
30s and 40s and um
you know what he did was he kind of like
kept rolling the plan out
in sections right like he didn't just
pop up on tv one day and go here's all
the steps
here's the end result now he started
with hey we need well
he probably started with r restrict
then it was remove and then once
everybody was removed
a lot of locals were like hey you
remember gary and everybody's like no
not really
things seem pretty fine without gary uh
the show
from the we are we the baddies come from
the mitchell and web look
which is a 2006 sketch show in england
just for anyone that was looking for it
any of the policies unfortunately we
need to remove it
and uh so we removed nine million videos
last
quarter that number seems a little high
seems pretty high a little higher um
and almost all of them over 90 percent
we were removed you know what i'm never
going to forget those 10 million videos
that you guys took down
and someday someday we will have entire
monuments propped up around the world
in memory of those 12 million videos
that you took down
and someday the children and the
grandchildren of those 15 million videos
that you destroyed
are going to rise up and they're going
to say never again
and videos last quarter um and almost
all of them
over 90 were removed with machines which
is good because it means if there's
content that's
oh good 90 of them of the 9 million
videos they remove with ai
just to show you what fair shake you get
on youtube
guys think about how much money we're
going to save
in like 10 15 years when we have uh
robot terminator cops shooting unarmed
black teenagers instead of having to pay
the [ __ ] guy you know 50 60 grand a
year plus overtime plus pension
plus benefits administrative leave
maternity leave
family leave sick pay all that's out the
window soon
someday we're just gonna have robots
enforcing everything
going around shooting your dogs and and
demanding we're gonna have ed 209s
demanding you wear a mask
and we're going to have robots in the
machines that stop your youtube videos
before they're even uploaded and i think
that that's amazing progress it's
violative we find that really quickly
and the second one is
is ray so the problem with with the
machine stuff right
the mach besides that it's [ __ ]
totally creepy like it's very skynetish
or matrixy the problem with the with the
machine doing that so the way it works
is whenever
now whenever you make a youtube video
right youtube automatically
translates every word you say into text
that's why the closed captions work so
well they really do work
well well now it translates into the
text and then while the video is
processing that text goes through a
system
if there's any words that pop you know
the thing the video will either be
demonetized or they'll take it down
the problem with that system is and the
reason that system is so flawed
it completely takes context out of it
like context doesn't matter anymore so
it's youtube is doing
like asset forfeiture where like you're
guilty and then you could appeal it and
they go look
my context so you have to fight for your
context
you have to fight for what you said even
if your context was making fun of it for
example
that's why when the ai's purge started
happening a lot of his history teachers
you saw
had their videos taken down because they
were doing lectures on buzzwords
it was all the buzzwords but the
buzzwords were in there because i mean
if you're talking about
there's no way not to have the buzzwords
in there sorry we've deleted your
account because you said many times and
you're like uh i'm a historian at oxford
university
telling them what happened yeah but you
know what royce i got to say you're
starting to sound like a bit of a spurg
you know we warned people she said yeah
but i mean you're acting like these
the behavior that you're saying that you
know susan and youtube are
allegedly displaying accordingly that
allegedly she said it
okay but then that would make them a
publisher not a platform
and that's not true so but it is
but they still have all the legal
protections of a platform why would why
would
why would the government do that why
would the government continue to give
pretex big tech a free pass to be
a publisher if if they've their platform
come on because google's giving them
money
oh stop uh we're all dead
so being able to raise up um
authoritative
information so for example raise up
authoritative information
remember this always hear these words
freedom fighter of the year she's the
freedom
fighter they give her
they're giving her a gold-plated statue
of patrick henry
i'm really glad at the rotc awards i'm
winning the big dick award this year
it's gonna be great i can be super
excited for it uh
well in the pandemic um we served
hundreds of billions of impressions that
came from different health organizations
like whether it was a cdc
but but there was also there was also
actual doctors that you kicked off of
youtube for not agreeing with them
can we now just do an award show
yeah and just give ourselves awards i
want most sober
all right cool
[Laughter]
i'm going to get best reader and i'm
going up there and i'm collecting it
dean martin drunk i want to thank
everybody for the award
barricade garage in the chat says her
albino woodchuck looking ass
here the equivalent and countries all
over the world
and making sure that people get
information from the right medical
sources
no no not the right medical sources from
the ones you deem acceptable you
lying question
question yes what if
oh this is a big if what if i made a
video
backing up dr fauci's claims that the
masks don't work
and then dr fauci changes his mind
and then i forgot i'm a forgetful guy
i'm lazy
i leave the video up because me stupid
stupid lazy bones
just left it up there and now i'm
[ __ ]
so now what do i do am i going to now
catch a strike yes
because dr fauci changed his mind and i
still the old video of saying maths
don't work
even if i make one that's his mask stew
work and then what if he changes his
mind again and then gets two strikes
i'm confused yes but let me explain why
i have an explanation
you're a racist yeah i guess that's fair
so that's the thing if you weren't a
racist it wouldn't matter okay so just
don't be a racist it's super easy that's
fair
in the case of kovacs there's a ratio on
this video
seven likes 3.6 000 dislikes
holy jesus you you wonder why youtube's
trying to get rid of the dislikes
do you wonder why but this i know we
always reference it but it really gets
me is
it's just that simpson's meme of like am
i out of touch
no it's the children that are wrong and
it's like
no matter how much [ __ ] gets ratioed
and downvoted and how much people really
and and by the way i'm starting to
notice on twitter which has always been
a very lefty place
i'm starting to watch the ratios on
twitter shift where people are
there's a lot of middle the road normies
that are now starting to be like
okay look man you've been gaslighting me
for like two years
and like i'm not a violent man but i do
want to start punching people in the
face soon like this is gay
like there's a bunch of normies now that
are going okay come on
man you're you're just lying to me did
you see the guy in minnesota that docks
the uh
uh the [ __ ] emt no she was an emt in
minnesota that donated get this
he donated to kyle rittenhouse's defense
fund how much do you think he donated oh
yeah yeah okay yes i do hear about this
i don't know how much you donated though
ten buckaroonies and this news guy
got a list and he went to this dude's
house and was taking photos of him
in front of his house and asking him for
to comment on him donating to the
rittenhouse thing
and he tweeted all about it he was all
excited about his big oh it's utah i'm
sorry
he was all excited about his [ __ ] uh
uh big story
he's getting great dude this guy just
got off twitter for a few days because
he's getting
[ __ ] and it's not all mike cernovich
types
there's a lot of normies that are like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
like a lot of people are going he was an
emt what's wrong with you he was an emt
a paramedic emt yeah definitely a
medical um
first responder guy and he had people
are like
like again not right winger they're
right-wingers that pile it on
but a lot of people in the middle that
are just going bro
what is your [ __ ] problem what is
wrong with you
that guy's just a private citizen dude
all because he donated you're not
allowed so i'm sorry
the kyle rittenhouse has not been found
guilty or convicted of
anything and even if he was you're
allowed to donate money to wherever the
[ __ ] you want
and and it's like people were pointing
out too it's not journalism it's
literally a crime to stalk harass and
intimidate people
that's literally that's a law in all 50
states on the books
to harass intimidate or coerce people
is a crime and that's they're not doing
journalism they're literally trying to
harass and and [ __ ] with this guy
that's that [ __ ] that's a crime you know
just because you have a plaque
just because you have a blue check mark
and a media platform behind you doesn't
mean that you should be allowed to just
straight up break the law
jesus [ __ ] crying and [ __ ] like this
is just more proof people just are
ratioing the [ __ ] out of people because
they're like
[ __ ] you and then what's the next stop
what's the next stop uh well how what's
because here's what's gonna happen
you're gonna get rid of dislikes right
just like netflix got rid of the rating
system right but
even without the rating system the only
thing it does is make us waste time
watching things that suck when we could
find out if it sucked
beforehand but we still watch it and
most of us still go
wow this sucked so like what's the how
do you guess lightest what's the next
level of the propaganda cause
once you remove likes and dislikes
people are still gonna watch these
videos and go
wow that sucks